it's great to welcome to the program
today Peter pomerantsev who is a
contributing editor at the American
interest and director of the arena
program at the London School of
Economics he's author most recently of
the book this is not propaganda
adventures in the war against reality
reality as well as other books some of
which I've previously recommended to my
audience so it's great to talk to you
Peter I appreciate it well thank you for
the recommendations that's really kind
of you so to start with give the
audience a bit of your background in
Russia and the places you've lived
because I think that's a big part of
your insight into what we'll be talking
about sure I mean like from a family
point of view my parents were Soviet
dissidents they ran into trouble with
the KGB in the 1970s and ended up being
exiled which was quite common at the
time and I ended up growing up in London
then after 2001 after University I went
back to Russia and ended up working in
television actually kind of in
entertainment television making reality
shows and factor in same I chosen all
these terrible terrible things a lot of
insights about kind of the development
of the Putin propaganda model because I
was kind of working near the belly of
the beast
maybe inside of it but not far away from
it and I wrote my first book about that
trying to define the way that the Putin
regime uses propaganda in this very very
you know I pretty original way what's
happened since then is that you know the
techniques that were honed inside of
Russia have been used for foreign
influence campaigns and my second book
kind of looks at in a propaganda across
the world how it's changing and things
about why Russia is particularly adept
at play the contemporary game and now I
you know I run this little things Hank
at the London School of Economics which
which studies that and thinks about how
we overcome some of the challenges of
disinformation of polarization and the
other pathologies that I'm sure your
your kind of viewers and listeners are
more than aware oh yes so I mean I guess
let's start with that in in the last
five to seven years or you know and read
the last decade maybe
are there ways in which what we are
seeing in the West reminds you of that
Russian techniques that were not as
visible in the West more than a decade
ago sure I mean even even you can go
back to the nineteen nineties and you
see these things develop there I think a
lot of is actually cultural rather than
just technical I mean this idea this
focus on nostalgia rather than an idea
of the future this kind of post
left-right moments we had a post
ideological moment where policies and
sort of rational arguments become much
less important and all politics just
becomes about capturing some sort of
feeling I mean feelings were always
present in politics but now the feeling
becomes everything this constant
redefinition of the people and the non
people has got a 21st century version of
populism this constant kind of like you
know mixing of different messages to
different audiences the the lack of any
kind of coherence for a successful
political movements and perhaps most
importantly this idea that you can't
hold power accountable with the truth
anymore this bizarre place were in where
politicians kind of rebel and lying and
even make a thing out of it and show
complete disdain for factuality and
factual language all of that was really
in in Russia already in the 1990s for
reasons I explore in the book then
there's also the technical side the kind
of the use of you know the use of of
troll farms are online mobs and cyber
militias and that's something the
Kremlin is already playing with in 2010
as a way to respond to to kind of the
Democrat Democratic use of the Internet
so yeah Russia's been somewhat of a
pioneer in these things partly because
it lost the Cold War by losing the Cold
War they ended up in a place in the
1990s were kind of all old versions of
the future of left and right politics or
the death of social definitions have
collapsed and so political technologists
that's a Russian kind of term for
propagandists and politicians start
experimenting with how to survive and
this kind of in in this new world yeah
so I want to dig into that a little bit
because
there are many in the West who know the
techniques but they don't necessarily
know the genesis and what catalyzed
those techniques to be pioneered in
Russia as you're pointing out and it's
very easy to just say add they're just
evil or you know it's conniving Putin or
these very simplistic explanations so
can you talk a little bit more about
what were the circumstances that led to
Russia being the place where a lot of
these techniques were pioneered well the
is also not seen historically by because
they lost the Cold War and then because
democratic capitalism kind of collapsed
is any kind of coherent ideology by 1993
in Russia with absolute disastrous
consequences for reforms and there's no
idea of the future left so making kind
of fact-based arguments about the future
became being pointless so instead there
was a reveling in nostalgia when I
interview a lot of these kind of spin
doctors were operating Russia in the
1990s they're like that we couldn't make
any kind of coherent policy arguments
anymore because all the coherent
rational policies were making people
unhappy so they said we just focused on
uniting people around a vague feeling
you know bringing Russia off its knees
which obviously anticipates making
America great again so that's kind of
the cultural moment but also you have
this kind of understanding that look you
can't do you William criminal
increasingly fractured world and
increasingly fraction environment and
you win by retargeting different
messages at different groups in very
honed in specific ways and you know in
the early 2000s which is when I was in
Russia that was so remarkable about that
version of polluting the way you to
completely transform for different
audiences so you know it sell the far
left one version of Buddhism but far
right another one and not even right you
always used interest groups here's your
what thing and here's your thing and it
didn't need to come together into a
coherent whole in a political
ideological sense but it would only have
to make sense again by uniting around a
very baby that anybody can interpret
their own way so you know what we see
Russia doing a bra
since then is you know massive really
funny completely contradictory audiences
whether it's the far-left and written or
the far-right in the US and sort of like
dragging them in to the Kremlin's web
and interests so you know the techniques
home inside the country have proven very
useful abroad but but I wouldn't
overestimate Russia's kind of influence
on things I mean you can only play you
know players sort of a tactical game
I mean what's much more important is
that we're seeing Western countries and
especially America arrive culturally at
a very similar place that Russia right
through the nineteen ninety-three we can
think of many reasons why all kind of
versions of left and right politic
collapse why all versions of the future
collapse for enough people 2008 crisis
the sense that people's children are
gonna be poorer than their we can talk
about many many factors but but in many
ways you know America culturally has
arrived to Russia in the early nineteen
ninety degree of course or in the sense
of its institutions or and you know it's
court systems and so on and so forth I'm
going to talk about like the political
culture but the permafrost underneath
there
the institutions of melting in a very
similar way when you think back to the
time where some of these techniques were
were maybe in in their heyday so to
speak and not to suggest that they've
diminished but maybe when when they were
more prevalent in a particular way how
did they or did they affect the personal
and family lives of Russians we have
sort of a sense you know in North Korea
of the way that North Korean propaganda
is woven into the daily lives with the
speaker you can't turn off with the
speeches and in sort of these other ways
but how if at all did the daily lives of
Russians a change by virtue of these
techniques that started being used
domestically listen I mean in that sense
Russia is not like North Korea
not let the Soviet Union it has when I
was there it's all had sort of the last
vestiges pluralism but at the end of the
day you can get information from the
West online very very easily there's no
kind of like Soviet style or Korea
self-censorship you couldn't leave the
country so that's in some much more open
system and what the Kremlin did was
realized that look instead of a sense of
the space they were flooded with so much
information disinformation people
couldn't find a way through this murky
world anymore in this dark chaotic world
you turn to strong leaders it's kind of
to guide you and they began to use
conspiracy thinking and cynicism as a
kind of quasi replacement for ideology
conspiracies you know weren't just a way
to sort of explain the world but the
propaganda pushed out non-stop the sense
that the truth is unknowable that we
live in this you know dark dark world
where conspiracy is layered on
conspiracy and layered on conspiracy and
in this confusing world you can't
believe in anything everything is
corrupt democracy in the West is rigged
and you need a strong Putin to protect
you and you know it's remarkable seeing
how effective that is a member now see
that across the world in Turkey and
uslar and former Yugoslavia and of
course in America where you know you
have a leadership that maybe they
believe in some of the conspiracy
theories which is really scary but they
definitely used conspiracy theories all
the time again to give people the sense
that the truth is unknowable that's a
big difference between 21st century
propaganda and 20th century propaganda
it's not trying to convince people over
truth it's trying to see it so much
doubt that people just lose the will to
struggle and live in a political sense
yeah I've said that it's much more even
though people like to say that it's like
1984 it's actually much more like Aldous
Huxley's brave new world in that sense
yeah yeah I mean I think I think I think
there is but better
maybe Huxley's is the better is the
better died I mean this
something that the Kremlin did early and
out of a sense of Christ said okay we
can't impose censorship what do we do
how do we impose what this Russian media
predict personally got so-called white
channeling just confuse people so much
and make them feel that uh no they can't
change anything that's the nasty little
thing about this conspiracy thinking if
you live in a world full of dark
conspiracies full of deep states and
full of you know endless media plots
then that means you the little guy can't
change anything it's a wonderfully
clever way of demotivating and
undermining that Democratic potential
the chroman code turns one out of
desperation you know and they kind of
like they had nothing else to work with
his imposing censorship you know that
really you know total censorship is is
really hard but I see now used across
the world
and and it's used in mature democracies
of the world which is very very
disturbing one of the things that I see
skeptics of Russian meddling in the u.s.
repeat very often here in the United
States are sort of isolated
counterpoints about where the current
administration's actions appear not to
line up cleanly with Russian interests
and what I feel like is missing from
these analyses is an understanding of
the level of sophistication and nuance
that goes in to a lot of these
techniques that are being used by Putin
where it's not about on any particular
issue necessarily getting the immediate
alignment on policy but it is about what
you're talking about sowing the doubt
destabilizing some of the main systems
that are used to make policy in the
first place making people question
whether the the democratic system is is
properly working as designed can you
talk a little bit about the the level of
nuance that is needed to understand that
just looking at well Trump bombed Syria
so therefore that that's just not deep
enough to really understand the level at
which these techniques operate yeah I
mean Trump I mean pulled out of serious
yes it's completely reversed of course
but it's yeah
Russia had already books I mean Russia
already had Obama's that of games area
so that that wasn't I don't think that's
what they were looking at um
look from what we're speculating about
what their game plan was but we assume
given on really the bits of evidence
that we have that the aim was to see
doubts so to push up Trump as much as
they could
assuming Hillary would win but then you
know getting ready in this narrative
that it was rigged you know that the
system's rigged that you know Trump lost
because the other side cheated
it's that sowing doubt which which is
kind of the meta-narrative all the time
that's the Marineris endure they use at
home basically you know getting say that
they're dumb nobody in Russia claims
that it's a healthy democracy or that
it's not corrupt their argument is well
the West is just as corrupted us as us
yeah then the whole world is rotten so
we assumed that was it you know that was
the kind of the game plan and then Trump
went and won and you know that may that
may have you know that may have been a
stunning to them was to us so um we
don't know but look Trump aligns with
the Kremlin in a very deep way
which is in his deep deep cynicism you
know when crunk Trump you know recently
we had transcripts from 2016 what Trump
hotels the Russians look I don't mind
what you did in the US because the US
government does the same sort of thing
that kind of equivalence is the essence
of kind of the Putin anti and the other
thing that seems powerful in that it
seems to me is that very often the
conspiratorial ideas do have an element
of truth in the sense that for example
the idea that the system is rigged and
democracy may not be functioning as
designed that's something a lot of
people on the American Left have been
saying for a long time but in different
ways then then became the talking point
after the 2016 election and that's
probably something that helps these
ideas self-perpetuate in society when
there is an element of truth to them but
the details are going completely awry
does that I mean it always mixes truth
and fiction or takes a good idea and
then pushes it to sort of an absurd and
destructive conclusion but look I think
it's quite a simple sort of divide
line there is a difference between
constructive you know policy suggestions
which should be based on criticism
that's fine and a kind of cynicism which
says our democracy is impossible .
therefore you know every system is
rigged therefore you know we should just
leave the world open to two strong men
and know all values are all universal
values are just a charade so therefore
let's have a zone of influence where
every country makes up their own by you
know their own system of norms and human
rights are just and there so I think I
think there's a difference between you
know a criticism that that's meant to
strengthen democracy and and you can
tell that usually by the by the speech
the nature of the speech because it
invites argument and genuine debate you
know there's lots of theories of
democracy which talk about that as it's
the nature of the conversation that's
important and this kind of
conspiratorial cynicism which ends any
conversation because it says well
everything's rigged therefore there's
nothing to talk about
so I didn't I didn't find it very hard
to differentiate between the two and I
think most people that they think about
it wouldn't find that very hard either
but but maybe on a certain kind of
momentary level you can fall for this
kind of party nonsense but I really
think people do I mean I hope not
because that's so depressing
so what degree do you see as what's
going on in the UK with Boris Johnson as
tracking some of what is happening in
the u.s. similarities differences this
isn't the way I encourage people to talk
about what I'm talking which is a
political culture propaganda is in the
formation of public opinion yes
political rhetoric which are the things
that I'm interested in that I compare it
to art I mean art is very similar in the
same way that it manifests itself in
similar ways in different countries so
you have you know in the turn of the
20th century you have modernism and in
Russia and the Soviet Union more began
soviet union in america and britain so
you have these common phenomena break
out because that's that's the tight guys
they'll manifest themselves in national
idiots you know they're gonna be very
very different in Britain to Americans
their different countries but without it
Boris Johnson as someone who's been
caught lying who lost his job as a
journalist because he lied and that
hasn't stopped him
means someone also sort of peddling
nostalgia non-stop so there are clear
motifs that repeats we've moved away
evening Breton was a move away from left
and right politics or centrist politics
which is the way to marry ensue to pure
emotions targeted messaging and a kind
of creation of the people you know it's
not a popular service an ideology it's a
strategy is a creation of an idea of the
people or a sense of the people for
every election so that's that's that's a
similarity but then there are a million
differences I mean Johnson and like
Trump is not enough you know he's a
highly educated man and cetera et cetera
and probably very different kind of
dinner companion to Trump so there are
huge differences as well but know
there's some sort of tight guys I mean
we see it in the Philippines of detente
with Obon I mean it's not a coincidence
that all these people are also men of a
certain age you know there's a lot of
similarities in my book I took a lot
about their language this obsession with
kind of jokes about human private parts
about you know like dirty jokes how all
of them
indulge in this language and what does
that mean what does that say about us
we've been talking somewhat about what
is in the book this is not propaganda
adventures in the war against reality
and about many other things with the
book's author Peter pomerantsev who's a
contributing editor at the American
interest and also directs the arena
program at LSE Peter so great having you
on I really appreciate your time it's my
pleasure any time